こんにちははじめ社長です
うまいどうですか皆さん私生活慣れてますか
まあ様々な人徒歩月から新生活が始まったと思うんですけれども
4月の中旬ですねそろそろ開けるんじゃないですか
そろそろだるくなってくるんじゃないでしょうか
知らないけどせいぜいかと最初は何しても楽しい市場終わったらしい人ばっかり新しい
環境
新しい部屋もうね本当にすべてがもう新しいでもなんにしても面白いですよ
全部相葉くしょんこけしでももう凄いですよねこんなにしては面白いって4月の最初は
面白いと思うんですけどもう
だろそれなんか誰婦だって言ってるんじゃないですか
5もう聞いてソロさっ参ったよ
友達ができませんこういったいろんな相談があると思うんですけれども僕が答えてあげ
ましょうよ
今回は僕に関する質問じゃないです皆さんに関する質問をこの動画のコメントにして
ください
僕の今度も僕げないの猫の心の器のでかい
もうもう神ですが紙管理ぐらいの
やってくると
もう自分のことなんてどうだっていいですよそうですけど聞いてほしいことが悩み事と
か相談ですね
そういうことをちょっとボスしようと思います僕はもう神なんでん
めっちゃ心ヒロインで本当にん
全部の質問は答えられないかもしれないですけれども
スゴみたいに聴いて欲しいなとかもっと質問はもうガンガン答えていくんでよろしくお
願いしますぼくの質問コーナーって言ったらなんかふざける感じがあるんで
あれなんですけどまぁおふざけ半分をはじめ半分みたいな感じで動画を作ろうと思って
いるのでいろんな質問をコメントにしちゃってくださいでは
皆さんがお困りやご相談があればぜひこのコメントについてください
じゃん
ban
2分